who is the king of speed chess Magnus
Carlson and Hikaru Nakamura clashed in a
battle between Titans Hikaru masterfully
conquered the early portion of the match
obtaining a 9-4 lead and in this game
Hikaru anticipated the pre-move winning
a piece and inciting this reaction from
Magnus when it comes to a time crunch
reigning bullet Champion Hikaru Nakamura
is just too dominant but when your
opponent is Magnus Carlson it's not so
easy despite being down Magnus
persevered and tied the match 10 seconds
Here Comes
you missed it tied match from there it
was an intense match of tug of war both
players fighting for the lead in
overtime that's when Hikaru defeated
Magnus 17-15 to take home the crown of
bullet chess champion for the fourth
time which answers the question